[Music]
paris
1565
on the bustling streets of the french
capital a strange new book has everybody
talking
whilst it looks unassuming from the
outside on the inside it's full of
bizarre and fantastical creatures
many of these monsters are comical
striking absurd and amusing poses others
are a little more disturbing with
unnerving expressions and emotionless
hollow faces
curiously there are no words to
accompany these drawings it's simply a
collection of 120 unique monsters
500 years later this obscure book is one
of the oddest things i've ever come
across
it's difficult to make sense of
especially as almost nothing is known
about the book's origin
although i have my own ideas beneath
these whimsical sketches lie hidden
messages that poke fun at the powers
that be
welcome to strange christian art this
episode
the demon doodles of 1565.
[Music]
the actual name of this book is the
dralatic dreams of pantagrawel it's not
the most catchy of titles i have to
admit but it's fun to say
drolatic is another word for amusing or
funny so the book kind of means the
amusing dreams of pantagrawl pantagrowal
is the name of a giant and the main
character of a popular 16th century book
called the horrible and terrifying deeds
and words of the very renowned
pantagrawel king of dyspodes son of the
great giant gargantuar or for short
pentagramel it's the first book in a
series of five they tell the story of
two giants and their comical
misadventures
so going back to our demon doodles these
amusing sketches illustrate
pantagrawel's dreams by the look of
things his dreams were very very vivid
we have an elephant holding a
weathervane
a bagpipe playing itself a demonic
backpack and of course a musical turnip
this is what happens when you eat cheese
before bed also i'm told some of these
doodles remind me of the paintings of
hieronymus bosch one of my favorite
artists who created these disturbing
hellscapes full of grotesque monsters
his creations were in turn based on
medieval art and the various creatures
found in the margins of manuscripts
these illustrated borders are known as
drolleries which is probably why our
book has the word dramatic in the title
whoever our demon doodler was they were
clearly inspired by the fantastical art
of the time
as these drawings were based on a comedy
book series i suspect that each one of
these sketches contains a hidden joke
as there's no text each one of these
bizarre images is a puzzle
a puzzle that can be solved
so let's try to figure out the meaning
behind some of them
[Music]
one of the first things i noticed when
looking through this book is that many
of these creatures have fancy outfits
from the one dressed in a scholar's
uniform to lavish suits of armor and the
one who looks a bit like gandalf but my
eye was drawn to this one in particular
a goblin in a dress the doodle reminds
me of this painting the ugly duchess by
quentin matzis painted around 1513 it's
a rather unfortunate portrait of a woman
i mean i guess the name of the painting
explains all perhaps reassuringly this
unflattering portrait was not of a real
duchess instead it's believed to be a
joke painting it makes fun of people who
refuse to dress their age attempting to
look young well into retirement maybe
our goblin in a dress is making a
similar joke inspired by the painting of
the ugly duchess
drawing a grotesque creature in an
exquisite outfit is one way to make fun
of the nobility
there are plenty of doodles that seem to
have a similar punchline
this one features another demon in a
dress behind her veil you can see her
shrunken eyes and large hook-like nose
poking out whoever our mysterious demon
doodler was they seemed really
interested in fashion and clothing
this has led many to speculate that it
was the french illustrator francois
despres he had previously completed a
clothing manual cataloging all the
different kinds of unique outfits from
around the world
you can see that the layout and style is
very similar to the dralatic dreams
perhaps it was the same person it's
difficult to tell
was behind our drawings looking at the
clothing might help us understand the
meaning behind some of them for example
this one although the first thing you'll
notice is its eerily hollow face with an
agonized expression aside from that
detail it's dressed in a rather pleasant
outfit kitted with a long flowing
shoulder cape and down by its side
there's a wide brimmed hat with the
tassels tied around the body of the
creature
this demon is dressed as a member of the
clergy with garments worn by catholic
priests at the time
from the same distinctive shoulder cape
to the large hat
if i add a little bit of colour to the
drawing you might see the similarity
more clearly
in fact there are two other doodles just
like this one with demons wearing
priestly outfits
both with those same wide looking hats
as before
another one is dressed up like a
cardinal a high-ranking member of the
church you can tell this again by the
hat
i like this one he appears to have
forgotten something although you might
overlook the fact that he's wielding a
giant knife
for some reason our illustrator dressed
his demons as members of the catholic
church
this might make sense when he considered
the historical context
these pictures were made during a period
known as the reformation
when a growing number of christians
started to protest against the catholic
church these protestants were unhappy
with the way things were being run and
began to form churches of their own
such religious disputes escalated into
bloody conflicts especially in france
which had collapsed in civil war three
years prior
violent clashes between catholic and
protestant mobs were known to erupt on
the streets of paris
gruesome incidents like the saint
bartholomew's day massacre of 1572
showed just how deadly these religious
differences could end up being
this dark backdrop shines some light on
our drawings by the look of things these
images were most likely intended for
french protestants who felt aggrieved by
the catholic church
by dressing these demons as members of
the clergy it secretly makes fun of them
now i love a proverb and as part of my
research i came across this old french
saying the outfit doesn't make the monk
it's normally meant to say that looks
can be deceiving
perhaps these doodles are trying to
illustrate this idea literally
we've seen so far that this curious book
contains hidden jokes at the expense of
the nobility and the religious divides
of the day
whilst i've tried to explain the meaning
of some of them i'm at a loss to explain
most of the others either way i thought
i'd share some of my favorite doodles
that this book has to offer
like a bell stuck on a shrub a snail
human with a human snail
humpty dumpty with a hal bird a jester
on stilts and finally a barrel with a
knife
these sketches are more light-hearted
and don't seem to be politically charged
i mean what could be the hidden messages
behind this one are there any your guess
is as good as mine
the dralatic dreams of pentagrel or as i
like to call them the demon doodles of
1565 is such a unique collection of
drawings these 120 sketches are so
fantastically bizarre and tap into the
weird art of hieronymus bosch and the
grotesque monsters from medieval
manuscripts whoever the illustrator was
they had a fantastic imagination and a
sense of humor too
some of these drawings make fun of the
powers that be in a time of religious
divide and political uncertainty perhaps
a good way to cope with it all is to
simply laugh in this way maybe these
sketches are some of the very first
political cartoons regardless of the
meaning of these doodles or lack thereof
it's fitting that they were supposed to
be dreamt up by a maniacal giant they're
indeed the stuff of fantasy
strange beings that inhabit the realm of
dreams or nightmares
depending on your perspective
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i had great fun
making this and i hope you enjoyed it
too if you wanted to see the full 120
sketches head down to the description
below if you like this video and want to
see more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye